i thought i was going to continue being
on television and having my own show
but i never i really never thought what
was going to happen after
50 and that at 59 i was going to be able
to be where i'm at
i always wanted to be a journalist and i
did that for 35 years and i was
enchanted
no one really thought that i could win
this race and be able to topple
one of the democratic titans i know my
people
i know they will vote for me and i
proved it even 20 percent of the
democrats hispanic democrats voted for
salazar
i knew that i stood for the values that
are entrenched in my community
the cuban americans the exile community
the immigrant community of south florida
and i said i can represent them because
they feel like me this is not a mar
this it has nothing to do with political
parties it has to do with your
conviction
conviction and with your love for the
american agenda the american
exceptionality
[Music]
i don't sweat the small stuff i'm kinder
i'm more compassionate i am
i'm here for the common good we're all
the same
we're on the same boat rowing towards
the same place
no one owns the boat we're all in the
same position
we just have to be kind to each other
and
know that um that life is an experience
and at the end you should not present
you should love more and and raise your
levels of awareness
and know where you're going and have
compassion for the other
who may not know where he or she is
going who may not have those
high levels of awareness who may not
have the compassion who may not have the
wisdom
and that's where i'm at
you